[Music]
good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation and I have a feeling
this is an exceptional audience how many
here have not been to one of these
seminars about long-term thinking for
long now before let me explain a little
bit about one of the things that you'll
be involved in which is that the
introduction cards you've got which are
instead of me giving a long introduction
have a question space on the back and
the format for this evening is that it
will be on the stage for about an hour
and 20 minutes before the end of that I
am Kevin Kelly having gone through
questions that you've sent up held up
written your question and held it up and
it'll come up to the front and I'll
bring the questions we have at that
point up to the stage and so be thinking
about your questions during the early
part of the talk and get them up to us
and then we'll proceed
this one is a interview and the
interviewer because this is the fifth
time on the stage Pierre Schwartz is
also one of the founding directors of
the long now foundation and the author
of a book called the long view about
scenario planning the person who'll be
interviewing is a government worker
and one of the things we've noticed
about governments over a few decades now
about thinking about long term thinking
is that it's one of the things that
societies charged governments with is
taking long term seriously and thinking
seriously about how to manage that and
take responsibility over decades and
even centuries many other institutions
humans are involved in do not do that
but it's one of the things we pay taxes
to our governments to take on probably
one of the most experienced people in
the world at dealing with government at
the highest level is our guest tonight
secretary George P Shultz Pierre all
yours
so look it's my honor to be on stage
with you secretary Schultz I think
you're wearing the only people's ever
thought for cabinet positions you and
Elliot Richardson you've served in the
military you've been an academic I
wasn't just in the middle I was I am a
marine yeah slipper pie everybody here
and artillery captain in the Marines
we'll come back to that experience the
Marines
you've been a professor you've been in
the government as far as I can tell you
the only foot job you haven't had his
Pope and maybe that little business too
yeah obviously so what I'm what I want
to do today just so you all know is we
have an enormous Lee rich history that
we can't possibly cover in the next hour
but I'm gonna try and cover at least
some of the big lessons from your life
in the first 20 minutes or so then we'll
turn to sort of the modern world where
we are today and where we're going what
it implies for the future and then we'll
open it up for questions from all of you
that makes sense okay what if they say
it doesn't make sense so when you were a
student at Princeton in the late 30s
early 40s you studied economics and but
you also started studied government
affairs was public service always on
your mind
well Princeton had a motto Princeton in
the nation's service so the atmosphere
was that's a good thing but when I was
part of his addition to economics was
what's called the School of Public and
International Affairs they had an
interesting thing each semester one
semester would be a domestic issue
another semester an international issue
so you international you'd have a role
somebody would be the Foreign Minister
of Japan somebody else would be the
secretary of the Treasury and so and so
you'd study what would a few were the
Foreign Minister of Japan what would be
on your mind and then they'd have
discussions and it was very educational
I thought so
after school you went to the Marines you
listed in the Marines you ended up a
captain in the South Pacific
and you served in the Battle of
palladium that was called a pellet of
Peleliu Thank You
Peleliu General William grouper coast
thought it was going to take four days
to win that fight instead it was a
couple of months what did you learn from
the the the challenge of a huge battle
that turned out to be much more
problematic than you expected
well you don't know what's going to
happen is this so you have to be ready
but I remember in the early days these
invasions are fantastic things you look
out there ships everywhere and planes
and so on it's an amazing Armada and you
land and then the supplies come in and
the beach and it's relentless so I go in
about the second wave and the Japanese
were there were caves on the other walls
on each side of the beach Japanese
wearing these capes taking potshots and
they sort of shut down the beach so
everything was stalled we were making
headway going in so I sort of took
command without anybody having me in
charge of anything and I said to the
guys okay you shooting that little hole
you shooting I don't know who shoot that
little Hall and we'll shut the Japanese
down and then we could get stuff on the
beach and that worked and worked I I
learned that if there's something
obvious get it done
that's a pretty good lesson so okay we
win the battle of Leyland
now it's after the war your professor
University of Chicago among the most
important people around the University
of Chicago at that time was Milton
Friedman a lot of modern economics but
what what did that experience have an
effect on you well the University of
Chicago had the most intense
intellectual atmosphere anywhere you go
to lunch me to talk I remember once I
came back then you know I just flunked
lunch but Milton was relentless and
arguer and his pal was George Stigler
hoon right it was fun
George's officers write-ups at mine
George and I played golf a lot together
so Milton was there a lot and I got to
know them very well and at one point in
the Vietnam War were you born then
just barely well yet not more the
students were active about it and I was
being in the business school and the Dow
Chemical Company came to interview and
when that happens they put up a sheet
and students sign when they want to be
interviewed so they had a big turnout of
students of one of them and they
produced napalm for the Defense
Department and there was a big hue and
cry about it and the head of the
university got a hold of me it said
can't you cancel this I said no the
students invited them here it's free
speech you have Nazi scum you have a
communist scum why can't a company come
just because they make napalm for the
Defense Department it's a perfectly good
thing but they persisted and then in one
of the trustees said I will hire a suite
in the Palmer House two Suites he said
and I'll have three limousines we'll
take students back and forth and they
can be interviewed there's no they're
gonna be interrupting campus so then
there were two faculty meetings and I
had on my side Milton Friedman and
George Stigler and Milton was the most
severe arguer on anything what's he's on
your side man you
and George had this ability to take
something you've said and twist it
around to get everybody laughing at you
so we had two faculty meetings and
finally my side one so we had the
interviews it worked no problems the
only concession I made was I got my wife
to make some sound I took them in
knighted by the dark chemical company
and I become that lunch with me so I
didn't have to go out
hence Morgenthau had a demonstration but
it it was a lesson stand up to these
things and it's important free speech is
important on the other hand I was one of
the student demonstrators at RPI against
out alright so that was like a
confession you were wrong so we come out
of the University of Chicago and you're
recruited for the Nixon administration
Secretary of Labor or is it OMB first
secretary Secretary of Labor and I think
something people don't really recognize
is you know a lot of irises student
demonstrator I was anti-war was not a
big fan of Richard Nixon but some
remarkable things happened under Nixon
he didn't start the war Kennedy and
Johnson right he inherited it agree but
you did some remarkable things as
Secretary of Labor and one of the really
interesting things was around labor
unions and a particular the construction
workers in Philadelphia when you tackled
integration in the labor unions and the
inability of blacks to get jobs in
construction tell us about that
well I'm when I became Secretary of
Labor they told me it was an impossible
job for a Republican because the
department was a wholly owned subsidiary
of l-cio and I brought in a really good
people a bunch of people and their staff
their knock themselves out for us so I
would say the people who are in
government the permanent career people
they are there to serve and if you'll
work with them they'll work with you but
at any rate one of the jobs of the
Secretary of Labor at the time was to
worry about discrimination
in the workplace and I had quite a lot
of experience with it before him and we
found in Philadelphia there were no
blacks in there in the skilled
construction trades at all zero for a
long period and it was obvious they were
perfectly skilled people around there
and so we don't we developed something
that called the Philadelphia plan we
said you've got to get some people here
and hire them and let's have some
objectives and let's have some
timetables for doing it so that became
very controversial in Washington and
alcohol before a Senate committee I'm no
no they sit up here and they look down
on you and so they said you're trying to
establish a quota system I said I'm
trying to replace whether it's been a
quota system here for a long time but
the quota has been zero it's been very
effective and the only way to break it
up and stand it with a sledgehammer and
that's what I'm trying to do but at any
rate they were finding a vote in the
Senate and the Republican leader Hugh
Scott from Pennsylvania gave me his
score she afterwards done I have it
framed in my office my side won by ten
votes Republican Democrats on both sides
of the issue but any right
it was a lesson and I was very heartened
by the fact that President Nixon
supported me all the way with that
hesitation I had learned something about
him earlier though he was a strategist
if you went to one with just something
no strategy doesn't like it but if you
have a strategy so I had been very
critical as a professor at the
University of Chicago at the tendency in
the Kennedy and Johnson administration
stater being in big labor disputes bring
him to the White House big deal and I
said when you do that you're ruining
private bargaining because if I'm going
to come to the White House sometimes I
may make breasts over till I get there
right so that kills private bargaining
and they were intervening in cases they
claimed would cause a national emergency
which I didn't think they were so that
was a strike in the East Coast
longshoremen and Gulf Coast's in 1968
and President
Johnson used the taft-hartley act a
enjoying the strike in the act there's a
provision for a fast track appealed of
the Supreme Court the Supreme Court
agreed with the president
so the injunction holes and it expires
sometime in the middle of January 1969
I'm sworn in a Secretary of Labor on
January 21st when the press says okay
professor Schultz now you are Secretary
of Labor what are you going to do so I
went to the President and I explained to
him I said your predecessor was wrong
the Supreme Court was wrong
this will not cause a national emergency
and of course a lot of our people in New
York City they think that's a national
emergency but it isn't economy economy
is resilient and if you can hang in for
four to six weeks once the parties
realize I'm not coming to the White
House I can get this mediated out and
that's the way it worked and so I got us
I've been one hand I saw with Nixon if
you went to him with a strategy then he
would work with it
if he didn't have any strategy didn't
like that but he was a strategist well
look you know I suspected there's a
number of people of my generation here
who led a very different for you like I
did of Richard Nixon at the time but in
hindsight looking back these two events
have just referred to the birth of the
EPA atw many of the kind of modern
institutions of governance were born
under Nixon how do we explain this
apparent contradiction between the
Richard Nixon that lots of people
loathed and this remarkably creative
moment in governance well there was a he
was a man of two sides apparently I
later learned you have the transcripts
of the tapes and you find he got with
his little inner circle and he was a
different guy and I've talked anything
Kissinger about he said I never saw that
side of Nixon neither did I
I saw the positive sign for instance
people don't realize that in 1970 the
schools in seven southern states were
still segregated by law
this is decades after the brown decision
so in 1970 Nixon for reasons I don't
know decided it was time to end it
and Benny and he realized that you had
to manage that so he appoints vice
president Magnum to be the chairman of a
committee and me the vice chairman and
Agnew would have nothing to do with it
didn't want to touch it so I become the
chairman and I in the White House at
that time was Pat Moynihan he was a
great friend and a good guy and a lawyer
named Len garment and a former advanced
man named Morgan
so that was my team and we decided and I
went to the president I said mr.
president we're gonna form biracial
committees in each state seven states so
we're not going to pay any attention to
their political party affiliation we
don't care we just want to have strong
respected people so that's what we got
and I remember the first group we
brought to the White House it was from
Mississippi
everybody thought they'd be the toughest
state so he brought him into the
Roosevelt Room in the White House and I
knew from my labor license experience we
would like to blow up steam and as long
as they're arguing principle you didn't
even get anywhere so I let him blow up
steam for about a half an hour and then
I quote in the Attorney General I said
what are you gonna do in the school's
over mr. Taylor said I'm gonna enforce
the law thank you so I said okay it's
been an interesting discussion this
morning but it's not relevant it's gonna
happen and the only question is is it
going to be violence what's gonna happen
to the schools these are your children
these are your schools these are your
communities so what are we gonna watch
the problems and what can we do and they
found that when once you get Americans
into a problem-solving frame of mind
they get very constructive and that's
what happened and by three o'clock in
the afternoon we were in good shape and
I took him across the hall to the Oval
Office and the president said here we
are in the Oval Office think of the
decisions that have been made here that
affected the security and welfare of our
country said well I've made my decision
on this issue but in our country that's
not you have to make your decision
if that's why you're here and we'll work
with you and he inspired them and we did
work but then we came to this last state
which was Louisiana and Patton I thought
we could do this we could bring it off
and why don't we have the last one down
in their hometown in Louisiana and we
can bring it off there and then we'll
have a meeting of all the chairmen
co-chairman of the different states have
them all together and to kind of kick
off the school year was getting close
so an oboe office meeting is held I make
my pitch the president the pitch treads
diagonal and president vice president
Agnes says mr. president don't go though
you be in a row and half the people with
black half the people be white there's
gonna blood running through the streets
of the south don't go so the president
looks at me and the non-politician the
room I said well mr. president whatever
happens it's on your watch and you've
met with these people and they've come
up here and you inspired them and they
haven't been idle they've been working
and we've been working with them and I
think it's a good thing to go down there
so he agrees to go so Pat and I go down
the night before we start meeting with
people it's going okay but not like it
usually does and suddenly darling me
it's one thing for to come and meet in
the White House it's another thing to
meet in the hotel room in your home no
it's not the same but anyway was going
and then I get Burt the president's ten
minutes out and so and tried to go out
and tell mr. president isn't quite like
it it's when you usually meet with him
you got to put this across yourself
which he did then we had the meaning of
the co-chairman of each of the groups it
was like a revival meeting they're all
saying if the thought of this brother
son of that from weinerman back and
forth it was really exciting and
reassuring so the schools opened and
there was no violence much to
everybody's surprise no violence no
bloodshed agna was totally wrong and it
worked
so that was another good experience with
Nixon
so we've now tackled labor we've tackled
education okay so let's move on
you're now Secretary of Treasury and oil
crisis hits inflation takes off lots of
us can remember being in oil lines
trying to find the open gas station
trying to find gasoline inflation is now
hitting ten 12 percent it's worse than
that
here's what happened I'm Secretary of
Labor and President Eisenhower thought
that if we imported more than 20% of the
oil we use we're asking for trouble so
we put it in the quota system we're
coming up close to that so all of a
sudden the president makes me the
chairman of a tablet task force on the
oil import program and we work at it and
we produced a good report it was
published and we said there's obvious
things
there's unsettle things in the Middle
East so we should get our imports from
there down as much as we could we ought
to have a storage system so we got a
little insurance policy we said we know
more about the subject than anybody in
the government there should be some
place in the government that's keeping
track of energy because it strategic
resource and a few other things like
that and it were perfectly obvious this
report was published President patted me
on the head said thanks for a good
report no congressional hearings nothing
was done so my lesson was it takes more
than a strategic analysis to get
something done so then I'm secretary of
the Treasury near comes their boycott
which is about what we predicted and
there was a lot of electricity came from
oil in those days so Christmas lights
were discouraged gas stations closed on
weekends it was a giant event and in
that area all the things we recommend it
got done one two three four seven so the
next lesson I learned was if there's
something critical then you can get
something done but you get it done if
you're ready if you're not ready the
moment may go and you don't take
advantage of it so I learned two lessons
out of that
but that also then took us to that
moment when the currency system broke
the inflation rates the different ones
and you helped end the Bretton Woods
system and create the new system of
floating exchange rates that really
transformed and liberated the world
economy to be able to grow and develop
well what happened was the system that
was in effect was based on gold and we
would offer to redeem gold and whatever
that will I forget the price but anyway
the way things were working there was
more money dollars out there than we had
gold in Fort Knox and there was starting
to be a run on the bank so to speak so
the president closed the gold window and
that changed the exchange rate system
and I was directed the budget and I kept
asking the Treasury people who were in
charge what's your plan and they said
it's a secret so then I become secretary
of the Treasury I said okay now what's
the plan they said we don't have one
that's what I thought so I had to think
of one and my friend Milton Friedman he
was sort of an unofficial God I said
both Milton I wanted to have a flexible
exchange rate system and my
undersecretary Paul Volcker said that
the Europeans of Japanese insist on a
par value system so Milton and I have
worked at it and we developed a floating
exchange rate system in the clothing of
a par value system and something more or
less like that is what's evolved kind of
a semi sloppy managed float that's work
reasonably well yeah but it's a it's a
loose enough system and a tight enough
system that it actually is both
manageable and it actually works and you
know that when people go off of it it
doesn't work very well and they learn a
lesson pretty fast runs on banks
courtesy crashes and the like all right
so you've now reinvented labor you've
reinvented education and the schools
we've transformed currency let's move
now to Secretary of State okay Ronald
Reagan appoints you Secretary of State
you were the second one who's Haig was
there briefly first
and he was moved aside you come in and
the Reagan era was a remarkable year for
many of us but there were several
moments that were really quite
remarkable and and one of which was of
course the Reykjavik summit when Reagan
and Gorbachev and you met at Reykjavik
something very similar to what has been
happening in the last 24 hours
so it wasn't similar at all nothing I in
the first place we had a way of
approaching these things and was first
of all be realistic Ronald Reagan said
the Soviet Union was an evil empire that
was a realistic appraisal of what they
were ii be strong we had a military
buildup we had a strong economy then and
we had to have you have to have a sense
of purpose that people are behind you
that strength then you say let us figure
out what our agenda is what do we want
don't pay attention to what the other
side might agree to because it's the
next thing you know you'll be
negotiating with yourself figure out
what you want and then engage so that's
what we did and we had negotiations
going on and the Soviets they Gorbachev
was supposed to come to Washington he
said let's have an interim preparatory
meeting and he said London or break a
big both of NATO capitals so we picked
break effect because it was relatively
isolated and we didn't know what he was
going to build up so we took a strong
staff and there was this a little place
called hophni house we have isolated
little place and there was a room on the
first floor not very big about the big
side of this rug and Gorbachev as
someone ends bragging is on the other
end I'm sitting beside Reagan Sheva
Nazis beside Gorbachev we're there for
two days and we talk about everything
but the first thing happened was
Gorbachev starts making Soviet proposals
that we're all our proposals are
you say and Reagan started to say some
thoughts I put my head as I'm I said I'm
talk he's just coming our ways delivery
but anyway it was an extraordinary quite
a time and in this hot the house
upstairs there was a big sort of common
room and there was a room for us in the
room for the Soviets so in the course of
that Paul netsy who was a wonderful the
public servant worked with me was there
and he he got to know in the counter
room marshal Akram a US Marshal a Khmer
was the top military guy in the Soviet
Union and it turned out he liked James
Fenimore Cooper will last the Mohicans
and Paul development got to know him so
after the first day there was an
agreement that we have two working
groups at night and Paul would be the
head of one of them for our side and
there were arguing with the Soviet
experts who would be on the Soviet team
into a chair and Paul said well probably
akame off it'd also be an expert said he
won't even be in the room they'd never
do that well he comes to the meeting in
Accra Memphis not only there he is
totally in charge nobody says anything
so we learned from that that in our
negotiation the fact remains that ready
to cut the mustard if he isn't there
you're just gonna waste your time he was
the dominant figure but there was
another negotiation to a woman named
Robert Wayne it was my assistant
secretary and she negotiated with the
smart Nicator and there'll be an
opposite number the first ever agreement
that human rights would be a regular
recognized item on our agenda it was a
breakthrough
so some incidentally see their number of
women in the audience it was an
interesting time because in the mid 80s
84 I guess there's something like that
and to have a new assistant secretary of
state for we call European affairs this
would be the point person in dealing
with the Soviets and so she would the
board this person would work with me and
I worked very hard on it because it was
important and I decided there was a
woman named Rose
which way who was the best possible
person and I talked it over with
President Reagan and he agreed and we
nominated her nothing happened then we
started getting weird from the Senate
back back together with draw this uh
negotiate this nomination we said no and
they're in the drawer and they said well
but this is a very important very
difficult job we don't think a woman can
do this job and we said well we think
she can that's why we nominated and then
Reagan who was very sly about these
things he started letting the word creep
out I was thinking about making a public
speech calling on the Senate to give her
a vote if you want to vote against her
cuz she's a woman help yourself but give
her a vote and all of a sudden they had
about of course she was confirmed but
then if then I have problems within the
government and particularly with the
hardliners in the DoD
and so we get to the geneva summon first
summit between regular Gorbachev and
Reagan and had the experience of being
in the big g7 meetings and there were
always a pre-negotiated communicating
and the free negotiate would have
brackets in it and they'd spend all
their time talking about the brackets
and Reagan said that's not a leaders
meeting that's a staff-driven meeting
I don't not gonna have a pre-negotiated
communique so that's what he said on the
Geneva summit ambassador to Britain came
in we can't have mr. God's have AB
renegotiated I said this my guy doesn't
want one and I said by that time I'd
gotten to know garbage operationally
well I said yeah if you push it I bet
you your guy doesn't want it either
they're both guys that want to grab
their own so anyway we go to Geneva and
obviously bras is gonna do the
all-nighter to create a communique and
the meeting goes really quite well and
the last meeting was on Soviet territory
and we're standing I'm standing with
Gorbachev Roz's there and the Soviet
people are gonna go straight over there
and I'm standing with Gorbachev and we
see Reagan off and so then I talked to
Garza all the things that are
accomplished
other words I'm sorry about lining would
be in the communique and he's agreeing
and he's making things and southern
there's a nice dinner Nancy Reagan knew
how to throw a party and she does dinner
party and everybody's having a good time
and I got a phone call
it's Roz she said we've been sitting
here for four hours and these people act
like they never heard what you and
Gorbachev talked about they're just back
in the Cold War and I'm just hanging
tough I said hang tough so I went back
in and somebody asked me what the phone
call was and I went after Gorbachev I
said don't your people paying attention
to what you said and so on nancy was an
upset because I'm messed up her dinner
party of the day but then about two
o'clock in the morning the Soviets get a
new instructions and Adam became
probably the best communicate we ever
got from one of these things we didn't
call the communicate we called a joint
statement to differentiate it and
Richard Perle who is one of the guys who
was tough it has to be on the delegation
I told him okay Richard but you have to
agree Roz is 100 percent totally in
charge and afterwards he came to me and
he said Bronson Ridgeway is the toughest
most skillful negotiator I have ever
witnessed anytime I can be on her team
let me know so that was the end of the
problems with Roz she proved herself by
confidence so you were there at the end
of the Cold War something you said to me
that trust is the coin of the realm
how did you develop the trust with
somebody like Gorbachev to enable to the
kind of steps that unfolded toward the
end of the Reagan administration in what
was then the Soviet Union to play out
where did that trust come from well I
think you have to develop a trusting
relationship with people friends or I'll
and it means whatever it is if you're
going to deal with them in any effective
way and the way to do it is to be
straightforward don't leak things to the
press it's just a private session and I
had developed that with shepper Nazi
with which each other in China
you you know go to the press you have
discussions for instance with China I
went and with dung shopping then what's
the chief guy and Moochie Chen was my
counterpart I said you put on the table
everything you want to talk about I'll
put on the table everything I want to
talk about and we'll make an agenda
Alabama and I'll agree to come here at
least once a year
Moochie Chen you'll come to the u.s.
once a year and about three meetings
here where we both go to the same
international meeting and will will
agree to carve out about three hours
just for us and we'll work our way
through this agenda and the Chinese
liked it a lot I'm it's very working
like it was Express and nobody was no
publicity about it at all we just did
these things and we got so we expressed
it at one point which I said to her
chi-chan
I come to Beijing you put me up in the
state guesthouse meetings along the
Great Hall so all I understand it's a
big country but all I know is there two
buildings on the road so he and his wife
took my wife and I on a one-week trip
around China it was really very
revealing we went to Shenzhen in
Shenzhen there's a place that's about an
acre or so and it's a it's China and you
can sort of walk around China and then
very these buildings up above I said
what are they so these are Chinese chefs
you think there's Chinese food there
were about seven different chefs doing
different kinds of food so all of a
sudden that hit me hard
what dunk champagne had told me namely
there's great diversity in China and so
that's one of the things that people
have to do in this world is learn how to
manage over diversity and diversity is
everywhere and I think right now China
is trying to do it by suppression or
ignoring it and it's there they're gonna
have to face up to it
so thinking about kind of shifting our
focus toward the future where we are
today and where we're going and I think
that was a natural bridge thank you
we we've lived in the last 50 60 years
through most of my life in a world
economic system that you helped design
and build
you're one of the architects and
builders of a global system that has
produced relative peace and prosperity
for 65 years it seems to be coming apart
right now it seems to being torn apart
you've talked about three big forces
demography technology governance as
shaping the future what's the future for
the international system that is being
pressed by giant forces like that and
the politics of Washington today
well the politics of Washington is
increasingly irrelevant I think we're
seeing the creation of what I call a new
federalism where we say there's a
problem here and we're people in San
Francisco let's talk about them and
solve them ourselves and for instance I
think one of the big things about the
future people don't realize how powerful
it is is the change in demographics
that's going on all of the major
countries have falling fertility and
rising longevity instead of being turned
upside down used to be the case where
there was a lot of young people and a
few older people and that affected your
retirement systems and everything now
it's very different there are fewer
young people a lot more older people so
you got to adjust to that in Russia
China Germany Japan
working age populations are declining
and certainly undergone continue there
are three countries where the fertility
and longevity are true but nevertheless
we're not declining in our working age
population those three countries are the
United States Canada and Australia what
are these three countries have in common
we're all immigrant countries every
person here is an immigrant or
descendant from Luna we're an immigrant
country
so I was once the guy who created
Singapore Lee Kuan Yew
was a friend of mine and he came to San
Francisco and I said what are you doing
here Harry and he said well there's
something going on down at Stanford and
Silicon Valley and we need to find out
about it a Singapore maybe we need to
loosen them a little bit so we're gonna
start a venture capital firm and be part
of it what you people doing in America
and I said when you get down there what
you're gonna find is there are people
there from all over the world he said I
know that but it could only happen in
America
so we attract the best of the brightest
and we also attract the people who have
picked the strawberries and it's worked
well for us I just hope we can keep it
going
so immigration wouldn't it be our
immigration policy well that's obvious
people in Washington have a hard time
with it but the things that happen you
say they're not us there was a woman in
Oakland who came here illegally 20 years
or so ago she's working as a nurse doing
a good job she has three children two of
them grown up working another one
younger and they come along that she
violated the law by coming in here and
they deported her and we say this isn't
on us and then you have this business of
taking kids away from their parents you
say and the idea that this is going to
cause parents to sober up said that's
not us that's not the way we do things
so we got to change them and have you
can have a regular immigration system
that's legal we do so obviously we want
to get control of our borders that works
and but it's impossible to get anything
passed in this legislation that we have
I might say incidentally that the people
coming from Central America you ask why
are they coming they're coming because
economic conditions there are not good
and there's terrific violence what
causes the violence we do our
or on drugs doesn't because the gang
sound there make huge amounts of money
by selling drugs in the US and they buy
guns and they have the money and they
have more resources and the government
does and they create a lot of violence
and people want to get away from it so
if we want to do something about it we
should do something about our war on
drugs and what could we do well it's
perfectly obvious this the war on drugs
started in the next administration I
remember and the president thought drugs
are bad for you so we should make them
unavailable restrict the supply and
people there's no supplier can't take
them so that's a software to solve the
problem and so that was the approach and
Pat Moynihan was in the White House then
and he was sort of a self-appointed drug
czar and he and I are driving up to Camp
David and I have a presentation to make
someone I'm directing the budget and I'm
studying my notes and he interrupts me
he said don't you realize we just had
that biggest drug bust in history I said
good work he said but this was in
Marseilles we've broken the French
Connection and I said great and there
was sort of a sound that he said to me I
suppose you think that as long as there
is a big profit of a man for drugs the
United States there will be a supply I
said wait and there's hope for you
but that's the problem no in Portugal
they're doing something that seems to be
working in a sitting it's not illegal in
drug drugs are not to take them or
perhaps small-scale possession in other
words for personal use it's not illegal
they maintain their legality so they can
go after pushers and they are the best
happily in treatment centers so right
now if you are on drugs you can get
thrown in jail the jails are full of
people and they get and associated
diseases so it doesn't work in the
cocaine use is higher and then you know
I said I always see other OECD countries
so it simply doesn't work but in
Portugal you can go to a treatment
center and with young people they find
they can really program get most of them
straightened out
older confirmed addicts are harder to
work with but still they have a place to
go so the jails are happening out and
the pushers are gradually losing they
don't have the profitability and it's
going away so it's sort of it's working
it's a problem you have to work on so
I'm going to come several of you've
asked questions about the current
politics and I'm going to come back to
that it toward the end but I want to
stick with some of the kind of longer
term forces first you when we're
backstage you were talking about both
technology and governance in your view
is transforming the world but in what
sense well I I think there are three
things when is it demography I've
already talked about that
then there's technology artificial
intelligence which really is machine
learning it gets a lot of publicity
that's really important to change you
lots and lots of things and then there's
3d printing which may in the end be more
revolutionary 3d printing means that you
can produce most of the things you want
close to where you are so that will lead
to a ton of a deal of D globalization
but in beginnin and it also means that
you can produce small very lethal
inexpensive weaponry
that can be attached to drones which are
cheaper so you can swarms of armed
drones it's gonna have a big impact on
security and we need to be getting after
that and then just as you have the
challenges to government produced by
demography and technology
I think governments are worse and worse
our own government all they do is
investigate each other in Washington and
if you look around Europe you don't see
anything very reassuring right now and
so the problems of government are
increasingly difficult and one reason is
that everywhere you're governing over
diversity and you have to learn how to
do that and mostly people don't know how
to do that I'll give you an example of
somebody who does and that's my
wonderful wife Charlotte she's the chief
of protocol and Keller in San Francisco
there's about 70 consulates in San
Francisco we were the most diverse
cities in the world so everybody has a
national day like we have the fourth of
July so in every country is a national
day she has a reception at City Hall
they fly that country's flag they sing
the national anthem and says welcome
we're glad to have you here your
diversity adds to our creativity and
you're here under the golden dome of San
Francisco
so that's governing over diversity you
recognize it but you also fit it into a
larger hole and I think people have to
learn how to do that but mostly they
don't so Kevin Kelly asked questions and
and we've talked about this in a variety
of ways over the the years his question
was in a few decades when China becomes
the largest economy and then later the
mightiest mightiest military what should
the role of the u.s. be well the US had
being in our foreign policy to be
realistic about what's going on in the
world to recognize that whatever the
problems may be we're part of the world
whether we like it or not I always say
that after World War two some gifted
people with the names like Truman after
and then Marshall and Clayton look back
and what did they see
they saw two world wars the first
settled in rather vindictive terms that
helped lead to the second they saw 60
million people were killed in the Second
World War they saw the Holocaust they
saw the Great Depression they saw the
currency manipulation and protectionism
that aggravated it and they said to
themselves what a crummy world and we
are part of it whether we like it or not
so they set out to change it and Britain
wasn't dictation it was working with
people but giving them leadership at
Bretton Woods there were 44 countries
represented and comes the cold war NATO
by the kind of cold war was over there
had been created a security and Economic
Commons from which everybody benefited
including us and that Commons has fallen
apart and we have to recognize we're
part of the world whether we like it or
not and so we have to be part of a
constructive effort to put the pieces
back together again it can be done but
we have to tap that out of it so what
would be a step toward putting it back
together again well you can I'm excited
I mean we're talking about trade deals
all the time there's a piece that people
forget namely that if a country consumed
more than it produces it will import
more than an export that's not an
economics that's not a negotiation
that's arithmetic
so you're not gonna get anywhere on the
trade deficit by fooling around you got
to do something about our spending
habits if you've got to do something
about the trade deficit so let's realize
that a trading system is good why why is
a trade good you don't make a trade
unless you think it's good for you right
so if we make a trade we're both better
off
that's what comparative advantage it's
all about
that's why economists are all for free
trade now sometimes people mess up and
they do things you don't like I think
it's fair enough to say that China has
taken advantage of things and has tried
to steal our intellectual property and
stuff like that and they need to be
chastised for that or work with to stop
it and people all over the world agree
with that point appeal and so there's a
way of going about it and to do
something about it but you need to
reconstruct a reasonable set of economic
relationships and then in the light of
all of these pressures that are there
for destabilization getting some sort of
understandings of violence and how we're
going to contain it is really important
and I think so and then I think they're
cutting across all of this the spread of
nuclear weapons people have forgotten
the how devastating they are a nuclear
weapon drops in the Bay Area it's wiped
out so not here anymore
these are awful things and then there's
climate change and climate change cuts
across and could do us a huge amount of
damage so we need to be working on that
issue very hard so coming I want to stay
with China for a moment and the u.s. so
is the implication of what you said that
we need to find a way to collaborate
with China and helping to build a new
world order or are we inherently rivals
not inherently rivals with anybody we
can have economic competition so
but we China is interested in the a
profitable world where they can get
along and so we need to be able to work
with them and just what the current
situation is exactly I'm too far away
from it but I have had a couple of
occasions to meet with Z and I was
struck by him do you trust him well I
don't know I would see if I were there
if I could develop that kind of
relationship but we hadn't used to have
a track to with China
Andrew kisser and I and a few other
people and before he was president but
he was designated it was going to be we
were in Beijing and he gave a dinner for
us and I sat next to him at dinner and I
knew it was going to Washington so I
said when she could stop in San
Francisco on your way to Washington we
have a Chinese American mayor and
they've done a good job and and you'll
be welcome there and he said well I'd
like to do it but I've already agreed to
stop in Los Angeles but then he said if
I came there what I would really do it's
like to go down to Stanford in Silicon
Valley where something interesting is
going on and I know you can't find out
about it by just reading about you got
to talk to people get a feel for it so I
was fascinated he knew that and he had
that point of view about how you learn
then and then there's something called
the sunnylands summit in the Obama
period and she sends word that he wants
to come a day early and bring his wife
that's a statement that I want to get to
know you and be able to have candid
conversations but we can really dig into
things and get somewhere and my wife
Charlotte gets an SOS from the State
Department which she go down to Orange
County Airport and help out she gets
down there there is no high federal
official there to meet the incoming
president of China nobody
so the first lady sends word that she
can't come at all because there's a
birthday of one of her children which
turned out to be the following week so
Charlotte sends an SOS to Jerry Brown
and he comes with him so at least
somebody's there to meet him then the
president of China cools his heels for a
day Charlotte I changed the first idea I
said what she like oh she's a beautiful
woman she's fun she's stylish she's
interested in everything she's an
operatic quality voice they have to keep
her stage appearances down what should
be more popular than her husband but
anyway a winner so the president of
China cools his heels this is not just a
missed opportunity this is an insult and
that's not the way you get along with
people now what you could do now I don't
know but at least I know that when I was
in office we had a very constructive
working relationship with the Chinese so
at least at that time it was possible
and at least the little contacts with
habit I've had with President Xi he's
the person you could work with but I
just say that from a distance I don't
know so I want to ask one last question
a kind of a deeper sense before I turn
to the present climate Nick who's a
member of the young professionals of
foreign policy where are you out there
Nick oh there you are okay so this is a
young future secretary of state up here
and he asked the question what skills
and experiences to the next generation
of civil service and foreign service
workers need you worry you are an
educator you were educating the young
future of government leaders what would
you say - I would say first of all study
but learn from your experience
experience is a great teacher
now here's three things I learned from
my service in the Marine Corps to Texas
take examples I remember I was at boot
camp at the start of World War two
Sergeant hands me my rifle and he says
to me take good care of this rifle this
is your best friend and remember one
thing never point this rifle at anybody
unless you're willing to pull the
trigger
no empty threats bootcamp wisdom we see
this bootcamp wasn't violated all the
time and you make an empty threat and
your word isn't worth anything anymore
so you can't I remember Obama drew a
bright red line against the use of
chemical weapons in Syria and they were
usually did nothing so that takes the
wind out of your sails so that's one
lesson I learned then another lesson i'm
i go from college to boot camp to
artillery school overseas
bing-bing-bing-bing so all of a sudden
I'm in war and there's action going on
and you have and you when you're you
become very tight relationships isn't
just officers man you and I had a
sergeant named Patton that I was very
close to and he was a terrific guy and
we had the sex and I'm looking around
for Pat and I'm running without patent
patents dead sir I'll never forget it
the reality of war sinks inland
wonderful people get killed severe in a
position to have an impact on a presence
decision to send people into battle
remember Patton be careful have a good
mission equip people to win and so on so
I learned that then we had another
incident we had taken this island and
there was and we were there and there
was a nearby island where the natives
were and then they just made log canoes
and grass skirts and stuff the Marines
like to go over by him and send him home
for souvenirs so I go over with the
Marines and we said you you can be here
for two hours then you have to go back
so the Marines obviously wanted to make
deals and I observed this to the natives
enjoyed the bargaining process so if one
party wants to make deals and the other
enjoys the part guess what's going to
happen to the prices it's a funny I had
to step in look you've set a price and
they could decide to buy or not but then
so I learned from that that if you want
to deal too much you're gonna get your
head handed to you and I can't remember
testifying before Congress when I was
Secretary of State and they would say I
can't work I haven't made a deal with
the Soviet you
and I said we're not interested a deal
we're only incident a good deal and so
if this good deal comes along we'll take
it but no deals for deals sake are not
worth anything so I learned that so I
say think about your experiences and
you'll learn a lot from those
experiences Stewart we started 10
minutes late do we have 10 more minutes
yes okay thank you you asked me okay so
before we one final question before we
turn to the difficult moment of today
when you look back at your own rather
remarkable careers is there something
that really stands out is the thing
you're most proud of that your greatest
achievement well you can't help but say
helping bring an end to the Cold War was
a big deal yeah but I think my most
thrilling moment a Secretary of State
was this one I worked hard on the
problem of Soviet jewelry many ways as
did President Reagan and there was over
the Neyman easier to tell who I met with
when I went to Moscow and you look over
these people and it's sort of impossible
there they are in this repressive state
and you'd like to see something happen
but it doesn't happen and one time I had
a negotiation with chevre Nazi and he
asked for a list of names I put a name
on the list I'm sitting in my office of
State Department phone rings I answered
and it says this is Eden O'Dell I'm in
Jerusalem I'm home that's my top moment
and you feel as though you had something
to do with a human being better off
that's what gives you satisfaction
that's a great answer
great answer all right let's get to the
difficult there are several questions
that relate to the current politics so
let me just ask the several questions
you can choose how you wish to answer
them because they're they're all
challenging in their own way
one question deals with can we imagine
the return to a bipartisan Washington
where the parties can collaborate
today's meeting with Putin between Trump
and Putin what's up
ask Kayla Horowitz the other by the way
the question if I would say when that
what's up what's down Oh Gina Rock
Innova yes the question about how we
restore bipartisan ISM John Brennan made
a rather strong set of statements today
about mr. Trump calling it his behavior
treasonous and Stewart Brand wants to
know that question was from Derek
Schwartz and still wants to know how do
you fix the Republican Party
so there's a whole set of concerns about
what's going on in Washington what's
happening with this administration the
divides politically how do you advise
people in this kind of a world I think
the professional groups the intelligence
community the FBI and made a very bad
expansion mistake in being public when I
see the head of the CIA on Meet the
Press I say are you crazy as soon as you
are out in public like that your
political I remember the first NSC
meeting I went to Iran named dick Helms
with CIA director and dick briefed
answered questions and then we turned to
policy and he got up and left the room
he's hand hung around the White House in
case they needed to have him come back
and inform us but he made a sharp
distinction between intelligence and
policy he did not want to be involved in
policy for fear it would mess up his
intelligence now these people have gone
off of that and we are paying a price
and we were wondering about the
intelligence and the same is true on the
FBI some of these things you look at
what the FBI has done you say what's the
matter with these people that's a
professional group they should stay out
of the press and stay out of politics
and so I think that's a problem but as
far as bipartisan is concerned it's I
just don't understand it but I would say
one of the things I learned was you
don't want things to be necessarily
bipartisan you want a criminal court
them into something that Salon partisan
our 1986 Tax Act which was very sweeping
passed the Senate 97 to 3 and it was
introduced in the House by Dave Kemp
hard it was the Democratic leader Bill
Bradley had the laboring oar of the
Senate and somebody asked President
Reagan if it bothered him two Democrats
introduced this legislation it was his
proposal and he said it passed it
so those were the days can we bring it
back is there anything we can do too
many of us are frustrated by the fact
that Washington is paralyzed by the
current lack of non partisan views what
do we do I don't know but I know this
most people in Washington don't live
there Paul Ryan for instance had to cut
his office his family is back in
Wisconsin
he said he he's leaving because he
doesn't wants to be a full-time dad you
can't be but they're not there it used
to be different the Secretary of State
has a nice little dining room and you
can get the president's box in the
Kennedy Center in time you were so I
used to have yet six or seven couples to
come in and have supper and go to the
Kennedy Center nothing have a don't have
to discuss they just get to know you
back and forth from friends and then you
have a better way of talking you develop
a sense of trust and it's hard to do
that under these circumstances I think
there's a nice theater in the White
House and President Reagan you're stuck
at a moving a new movie and you got a
couple of movie stars to come and invite
people to come and they'll have a thing
just have a nice time see a movie have a
little reception afterwards so you get
to know people and that's what you're
doing and Tip O'Neill somebody asked
President Reagan Tip was this ever so he
said not after six o'clock so one final
question you you have to be a profoundly
optimistic human being to have lived the
life you've lived you've experienced
America over the last century almost
what sustained your optimism what gives
you but the most hope for the future
well I have seen it time and time again
that there's some big problem we deal
with it effectively the US has a
fantastic record of digging in and
solving problems and I think we can do
that
but I think that something is taking
place and not so sure this but it's an
observation I think we see a new
feminism emerging remember our founding
fathers put together a constitution that
basically said in in the center there's
going to be something that has to do
with foreign policy and defense policy
but most things were left to the states
and localities and gradually the federal
government has filled up that space they
even tell us how to run a bathroom come
on we figure out how to do it our way so
I think there's kind of a push back
starting we're starting to say more lets
us figure out our problems and do
something about them ourselves and I
think more and more that is starting to
happen so do you stand with Jerry Brown
as he's now actually making California
great again well we're a pretty great
state and we have a lot of problems but
I love it here I mean if you go on
outside recently not bad with that let
me say thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]